[موسيقى]
تعالى
وبركاته سعيدين جدا يعني
بمشاركه المحفل هنا او يعني محفل تدكس
سمعته عالميه طبعا زي ما قال الدكتور نحنا
بنمثل مركز مناظرات السودان وهو مركز حديث
بيعنى بتوطين فن المناظره باعتبارها اداء
بتساعد على ترسيخ يعني ثقافه الديمقراطيه
في المجتمع الديمقراطيه من ناحيه قاعديه
الى الى الاعلى انا ابو بكر اسماعيل نائب
المدير التنفيذي في مركز المناظرات
المناظره الليله حتتكلم عن سؤال القبيله
في السودان نظرا لضيق الوقت فانا حديكم بس
النموذج حيكون عامل كيف وح اشرح لكم او
حديكم العنوان بتاع القضيه القضيه
هي سؤال القبيله في الاوراق الثبوتيه يرى
هذا المجلس انه يجب الغاء سؤال القبيله في
الاوراق الثبوتيه متحدث الموالاه او
متحدثه الموالاه عندنا الطالبه نجاه او
الخريجه نجاه محمد سليمان صفقه
لنجاه ثاني عندنا في المعارضه احمد الطيب
حياتي صفقه لاحمد الطيب
حياتي المناظره فترتها نصف ساعه حيكون في
ثلاث خطابات الخطاب الاول اي خطاب من
الثلاثه خطابات دي مدته خمس دقائق الخطاب
الاول بيتم فيه شرح الكلمات الاساسيه
وتعريف القضيه وتقديم المرافعه الاوليه
اللي بيشرح فيها المتناظر موقفه ووجهه
نظره في الموضوع في المقابل حندي الفرصه
لمتحدث المعارضه حيقوم برضو نفس الشيء
يعرف القضيه ويحدد موقفه منها ويقدم
مرافعته الاوليه ده الخطاب الاول بالنسبه
للخطاب الثاني فهيكون فيه استكمال للحجاج
يعني وحيكون فيه بطبيعه الحال ردود
واشتباك يعني بين وجهات النظر اما الخطاب
الثالث وطبعا كل خطاب زي ما قلنا مدته خمس
دقائق الخطاب الثالث فهو خطاب التفنيد
المتحدث وظيفته الاساسيه انه يفند الخطاب
بتاع تحدث الخصم وعشان ما نطيل عليكم نحنا
حنبدا بعد نقدم المناظره الطالبه اول
دكتوره نجاه محمد
[تصفيق]
تفضلي
احبك جدا رغم ان في قبيلتي ومدينتي وسلاسل
العادات الحضور الكريم لجنه التحكيم
الموقره صديقي في فريق المعارضه السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته جئنا
اليوم
لنتناقش الراي السوداني لفتره طويله وهي
قضيه الغاء سؤال القبيله في الاوراق
الثبوتيه الغاء السؤال عن القبيله في
الاوراق الثبوتيه اتيتكم في فريق الموالاه
مواليه لهذا الغرار جمله
وتفصيلا ولكن في البدء سابدا بتعريف بعض
الكلمات لكي تكون المناظره سهله ميسره على
الفريقين اما الاوراق الثبوتيه فنقص بها
هي الاوراق المستخدمه كادل للاثبات كالهو
الشخصيه مثلا كالجنس سابقا والرقم الوطني
او البطاقه القوميه
حاليا سياق المناظره سيكون هو السياق
الواقع السوداني اما المشكله التي نطرحها
اليوم ونطرح لها قضيه هذه المناظره هي ان
السؤال عن القبيله في المجتمع السوداني
اصبح مؤشرا للعنصريه
القبليه الهدف من هذه الموالاه هو تعزيز
مفهوم المواطنه الامنه تعزيز مفهوم
المواطنه
الامنه ولكن في البدء دعونا نتفق على شيء
معين وهو ان الغاء السؤال من الاوراق
الثبوتيه ليس بالضروره وحده قادرا على
محاربه العنصريه القبليه في السودان ولكنه
يمث ولكنه يمثل احد الوسائل التي يمكن
استخدامها للتقليل من حده هذه القبليه لكي
اوالي هذا النص جئتكم وفي معيتي محاجته
المحاجه الاولى ستجيب على سؤال لماذا يجب
الغاء سؤال القبيله في الاوراق الثبوتيه
المحاجه الثانيه ستتعلق بلماذا الاوراق
الثبوتيه تحديد دا ليس
غيرها في نقطتي الاولى التي تتحدث عن
لماذا الالغاء جميعنا يعلم علاقه الشعب
السوداني بالانتماء القبليه ندعي الطيبه
وندعي التعامل المشترك ندعي احترام الاخر
واحترام التنوع ولكن في الحقيقه حينما
ناتي الى محكات الحياه الحقيقيه ربما نرفض
احدهم الذي اتى ليطلب يد ابنتنا للزواج
فقط لعرقه لا لشيء اخر وطالما ان مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الان تضج بالصراحه فمن
الاولى ان نكون صريحين مع انفسنا في
المرتبه الاولى سجلاتنا حافله بالممارسات
العنصريه ومواقف الحياه تحكي بذلك الالفاظ
التي نستخدمها لنن عت بها بعضنا
البعض وهذه للاسف ليست ممارسه شعبيه وحسب
بل حتى على مستوى الدوله نجد ان التفرقه
العنصريه على اساس القبيله حاضر
وبشده في واقع كهذا في واقع كهذا الواقع
توجد فيه هذه الممارسه على المستوى الشعبي
وعلى مستوى الدوله وايضا على مستوى
المدينه والريف قد تختلف الحده قليلا في
المدينه ولكن الممارسه موجوده نجد بان
التصريح
بالقبيله ليس بالعمليه الامنه لماذا لان
العقل الجمعي للمجتمع السوداني سيجعلك في
هرم المواطن المواطنه المناس لك حينما
تصرح بالقبيله نقوم بتصنيفه مباشره على
اساس هرم المواطنه الشعبي ربما تتسائلون
ما هذا الهرم هذا الهرم قد وضع نتيجه
لاسباب كثيره اختلف المؤرخون على نشاتها
ولكن ما يحدث حاليا هو انك تعتل الهرم
كلما اقتربت من العروبه والدين الاسلامي
وتبتعد منه كلما لم يحالفك الحظ في
الاقتراب لان هذا السؤال تحديدا يوجد
متضررين من من طرحه وهم الذين تقع عليهم
العنصريه وهم الذين يقعون في اسفل هذا
الهرم كان هنالك الزام اخلاقي من الدوله
لكي تقوم بسن تشريعات للتقليل من حده هذه
العنصريه او لحمايه المواطنه المتساويه
اذا دقيقه واحده السؤال في حد ذاته ليس
مشكله ولكن المجتمع السوداني ونتيجه
للاسباب التي ذكرتها لديه حساسيه تجاه هذا
السؤال عندما اقول لدي حساسيه تجاه شيء
معين ليس بالضروره ان هذا الشيء سيء لذاته
فانا اتحسس من الفول السوداني مثلا ولكن
ليس لان في الفول السوداني مشكله لانني
انا اتفاعل معه بطريقه تسبب لي مشاكل صحيه
اذا سؤال القبيله في حد ذاته ليس مشكله
ولكن طبيعه المجتمع السوداني لا تتقبل هذا
السؤال بصوره معرفيه وانما بصوره تصنيفه
في المقام الاول لذلك جئنا موالين على هذا
القرار لكي نمنع ما يترتب على التصريح
بالانتماء
القبلي نرجو للمحو هذا المحمول السيء الذي
وضع للسؤال سؤال القبيله بصوره عامه في
الاوراق الثبوتيه او غيرها له حساسيه
مفرطه في المجتمع السوداني شكرا على حسن
الاستماع وعمق
[تصفيق]
الانصات نشكر الان نشكر الطالبه نجاع على
خطابها الذي استمر خمس دقائق الفرصه الان
متاحه لمتحدث المعارضه احمد حياتي فليتقدم
ليسمعنا
خطابه يقول فرانسيس فوكوياما في كتابه
نهايه التاريخ ان ما يرضي البشر حقا ليس
الوضع المادي بقدر ما يرضيهم الاعتراف
بوضعهم وكرامتهم الجمهور الكريم الساده
الافاضل الزميله في فريق الموالاه التي
توالي قرار المجلس الذي ينص على يجب الغاء
سؤال القبيله يجب الغاء السؤال عن القبيله
في الاوراق الرسميه السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله تعالى ومرحبا
بكم اقف امامكم وانا اتبنى موقف ال ربما
يكون غريبا للبعض الا وهو انني اعارض
الغاء سؤال القبيله من الاوراق
الثبوتيه هادفا من هذه المعارضه الى تعزيز
ثقافه الاعتراف ثقافه الاعتراف بالاختلاف
وتقبل الاخر وتقديم نوع تنميه نوعيه لهذه
البلاد ولكن قبل ان اقوم بالتبرير لهذا
الموقف الغريب دعوني انظف هذه المنصه مما
قد قيل فيها قبل قليل من حديث
المتحدثه المواليه مقه قالت اولا انها ترد
انها انها ان هذا السؤال اصبح مؤشرا
للعنصريه القبليه ولكن يجب ان نسال انفسنا
سؤالا هل القبيله هي عيب وعار وهل القبيله
تؤدي مباشره للعنصريه نحن ربما عن طريق
الوعي الزائف فهمنا العنصريه فهما خاطئا
وجلسنا وقمنا بربطها بمفاهيم شكرا جزيلا
وقمنا بربطها بمفاهيم اخرى قالت انها تسعى
الى تعزيز مفهوم المواطنه الامنه ولكن هل
تتعارض القبيله مع مفهوم الم المواطنه
اولا يوجد قانون يمكن ان تقف القبيله عنده
اذا ارادت ان تتعدى على مفهوم المواطنه
الامنه قالت ايضا في حجتها ا اننا نود تح
تحطيم الهرم الاجتماعي ولكن كيف كيف نحطم
هذا الهرم ونحن نهرب من مواجهته كيف نحطم
هذا الهرم ونحن نرى ان السؤال عن القبيله
يعتبر عيبا وعارا يجب اخفائه يجب علينا يا
سادتي ان نواجه مساوي ان نقف امام هذه
المشكله وان نواجهها وان نعري نعري
العنصريه من المفاهيم الكثيره الملتصقه
بها قالت
انه ان العنصريه موجوده نعم اتفق معك يا
عزيزتي وان العنصريه موجوده في جميع
تعاملاتنا وان هذا السؤال ربما قد يؤدي
الى حدوث مشاكل في الشارع السوداني ولكن
يجب علينا ان ننظر الى هذا المنطق الاعوج
الذي استخدمته المتحدثه فاذا حدثت بعض
التحرشات بالفتيات في الشارع السوداني هل
الحل ان ان نقول للفتيات ان تجلسوا في
المنازل ولا تظهروا اطلاقا اذا حدثت ا
مشاكل بسبب اسم القبيله ليس الحل ان نقوم
بالغاء هذا السؤال من الاوراق الثبوتيه بل
الحل يكمن في ان سنه قوانين تمنع العنصريه
وتمنع التلفظ بالالفاظ العنصريه هذا ردا
على ما قالته المتحدثه زميلتي في فريق
الموالاه اذلف الان الى ذكر موقفي والذي
كما قلت مسبقا انه يعتبر غريبا اعارض هذا
القرار هادفا من هذه المعارضه تعزيز ثقافه
الاعتراف اختلاف وتقبل الاخر وتقديم تنميه
نوعيه لهذه البلاد لدي في سبيل ذلك حجتين
الحجه الاولى تتعلق بالاعتراف بالتنوع
ومواجهه العنصريه والحجه الثانيه تتعلق
باحصاء بان احصاء القبائل وافرادها يسهل
من عمليه التنميه
النوعيه اما في الحجه الاولى نعلم جميعا
يا سادتي ان هذا السودان يوجد به اختلاف
قبلي ضخم جدا جدا جدا ا يتمثل فيما يقارب
ال 520 قبيله تنقسم الى ال 56 او 57 اثنيه
حت حسب اخر اعصا وقمه في السودان جميع هذه
المكونات وجميع هذه الثقافات وجميع هذه
القبائل الموجوده في هذه البلاد يجب عليها
ان تتعايش مع بعضها البعض ويجب عليها ان
تنهض بهذه البلاد الى الامام ولكن نظرا
لاختلاف هذه الثقافات الكثيره ونظر
لاختلاف هذه القبائل الكثيره في عاداتها
وفي تقاليدها تحدث العنصريه وتحدث المشاه
هنات فاذا اردنا ان ننهض بهذه البلاد يجب
علينا اولا تبقت دقيقه يجب علينا اولا ان
نعترف باننا مختلفون ومن ثم ان نتقبل
بعضنا البعض حتى نستطيع النهوض بهذه
البلاد وكيف نعترف باننا مختلفون ونحن نرى
في سؤال القبيله عيبا وعارا عندما تقوم
هذا الاعتراف الذي اتحدث عنه يكون على
مستوين على مستوى الدوله ويكون في الاوراق
الثبوتيه وان تعترف الدوله بوجود جميع هذه
القبائل والاعتراف يكون على مستوى المجتمع
وهذا يمكن التحدث عنه في منطقه ثانيه لذلك
اعتقد انه يجب على الدوله ان تعترف بوج
وجود جميع هذه القبائل ويجب على جميع
افراد هذه القبائل الاعتراف والافتخار
باسامي قبائلهم في الاوراق الثبوتيه وفي
جميع المحافل الاخرى حتى نعري هذه
المفاهيم حتى نعري العنصريه من هذه
المفاهيم السالبه ان هذا
الانسان ان هذا الانسان الذي يخجل من ذكر
اسم قبيلته لقد سيطرت عليه العقليه
الانهزاميه والهرم الذي تحدثت عنه زميلتي
في فريق الموالاه هذا الهرم يجب علينا
تحطيمه ويجب علينا ان نعلم ان جميع
القبائل متساويه وشكرا زيلا
لكم نشكر المتحدث احمد حياتي على مرافعته
التي استمرت خمس
دقائق اي نشكر الطالب ممد حياتي على
مرافعته الانيقه والتي استمرت خمس دقائق
الفرصه الان لمتحدث الموالاه كي ما تقدم
خطابها والذي سيستمر كذلك خمس دقائق تفضلي
يا
نجات
السلام عليكم
مجددا قبل ان انتقل الى نقطه الثانيه
والتي تتعلق بلماذا نريد القاء هذا السؤال
في الاوراق الثبوتيه تحديدا سابدا بتفنيد
بعض ما قاله متحدث المعارضه الاستاذ احمد
ابتداء من الهدف وانتم تعلمون حينما يهدم
الهدف تضيع الوجهه وهذا ما سيحدث ذكر بان
هدفه من المعارضه هو تعزيز ثقافه تقبل
الاخر واحترام
التنوع للتسهيل من عمليه التنميه النوعيه
يا ساده نحن منذ العام 2005 ندلي باسماء
قبائلنا في الاوراق الثبوتيه هل شهدنا هذه
التنميه
النوعيه تح تساءل تساءل عن هل القبيل عار
ومن قال ان القبيله عار نحن نعترف
بالقبيله ككيان اجتماعي ثقافي موجود حفظ
لنا الكثير من ثقافتنا والى الان موجود
نحن نعارض ما يترتب على القبيله نحن نعارض
التعامل حسب الانتماءات القبليه وليس
القبيله كشيء موجود ونحترمه قال بان مفهوم
القبيله لا ينهي مفهوم المواطنه وانا
اتحدى اي شخص في الحضور اذا سمع اساءه
متعلقه بالسودان ربما يعتبرها نكته ويضحك
ولكن حينما تتم الاساءه الى قبيلته فلن
يسلم في ذلك راس تحدث
ايضا تحدث ايضا
عن هرم المواطن الذي ذكرته وقال كيف نحطم
هذا الهرم اذا كنا نهرب من السؤال نحن لا
نهرب من السؤال مجتمعنا غير قادر على تقبل
هذا السؤال والتعامل معه بطريقه معرفيه
اذا لم نحطم هذا الهرم فمن سيتحطم هم رؤوس
الذين تمارس عليهم العنصريه هم الذين
يعانون منها يوميا والجمره بتحرق ال
اما بخصوص حجته المستقله والتي ذكر فيها
بان السودان بلد التنوع اذا من الطبيعي ان
توجد عنصريه لاننا مختلفون في هذا دعوه
واضحه الى تطبيع العنصريه وجعلها شيئا
طبيعي اما بقي بان السودان بلد التنوع
المشكله ليست في التنوع المشكله في عدم
احترام التنوع المشكله في سوء اداره هذا
التنوع اما بخصوص محاجته الثانيه والتي
اثبت فيها موقفي في الموالاه لماذا
الاوراق الثبوتيه تحديدا ان الذهاب
لاستخراج الاوراق الثبوتيه هو اعتراف رسمي
بالمواطنه وموضع مناسب لاعلاء الحس القومي
وبالتالي نحن نتوقع ان في هذا الاجراء
يفترض التاكيد على المواطنه والانتماء
للوطن فحينما يطرح سؤال في هذا الموضع
يطرح سؤال قبيل تك شنو يتم الترسيخ لفكره
الانتماء القبلي بصوره كبيره وهذا يؤدي
الى توليد ما يسمى بالانتماء المزدوج اي
اي الانتماء الى القبيله اولا ثم الانتماء
الى الوطني ثانيا وفي حاله كحاله السودان
كما اوضحت وشرحت باننا نعايش هذه
المعاملات بصوره يوميه تنتصر القبيله بلا
منازع ونؤثر بذلك سلبا على على الاحساس
بالهويه القوميه تلك القوميه التي لا نسعى
اليها في السودان نحن وسب وانما يسعى
اليها العالم اجمع الاحساس بالقوميه
الاحساس بالملكيه المشتركه الى السودان
لذلك تحديدا لا يمكننا ان نقحم السؤال عن
القبيله في منطقه استخراج الاوراق
الثبوتيه التي يفترض ان تدل على المواطنه
اي مواطنه المواطنه الى السودان وليست الى
قبيله
مختلفه وحتى نصبح وحتى نصبح في مرتبه
معرفيه تجعلنا قادرين على تقبل سؤال
القبيله فقط كسؤال معرفي للتعرف على الاخر
ولتبادل الثقافات حينها فقط يمكننا ان
نضيفه اما غير ذلك فلا نؤكد موالات هنا
لالقاء هذا القرار جمله وتفصيلا شكرا على
حسن الاستم
[تصفيق]
مع نشكر الطالبه نجاه على خطابها الثاني
والذي استمر اربع دقائق كان خطابا فصيحا
بليغا اما الان فالفرص متاحه لمتحدث
الموالاه ليقدم خطابه
الثاني
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
نعود اليكم مره اخرى لنتحدث في هذه
المناظره التي اتى نصها يعتقد هذا المجلس
انه يجب الغاء السؤال عن القبيله في
الاوراق
الثبوتيه وعلى نفس النهج الذي اتخذته قبل
قليل ساقوم بتفنيد حديث متحدثه الموالاه
والتي كانت قبلي ومن ثم اعود الى بناء
موقفي مره اخرى اولا يا عزيزتي ادعيني
اعطيك درسا في معنى المواطنه عندما نتحدث
عن مفهوم المواطنه فان نحن نتحدث عن فرد
له حقوقه له حقوق عليه واجبات بينه وبين
الدوله اما في المثال الذي ذكرتيه انه اذا
تمت الاساءه الى قبيله ما في هذا الحشد
فانه سوف ينفعل فهذا شيء طبيعي لا يلغي
بالضروره مفهوم المواطنه لان انفعاله من
اجل قبيلته يتم قياسه اذا كان هذا اثر على
مفهوم الحقوق والواجبات هل تعدى حقوقه هل
تعدى حدود
في انفعاله لقبيلته ام
لا قالت في حديثها ان الاوراق الثبوتيه هي
مكان للاعتراف هي مكان اعتراف رسمي
بالمواطنه اولا يتم استخدام الاوراق
الثبوتيه في معاملات كثيره جدا ومن اجل
ذلك يتم السؤال عن اشياء كثيره جدا تدخل
في طبيعه الحياه اليوميه وفي طبيعه
المعاملات اليوميه يتم السؤال عن تاريخ
الميلاد يتم السؤال عن الجنس اذا كان ذكر
او انثى عن مكان الميلاد وهذه الاشياء
موجوده في الواقع ايضا القبيله موجود
موجوده في الواقع ويمكن التعامل بها من
اجل تحقيق سياسات للتمييز الايجابي لذلك
يجدر ايضا السؤال عن القبيله في هذا
الموضوع تحدثت اننا يجب ان اننا يجب ان
نحقق القوميه ولكن يا عزيزتي جميع
المحاولات السابقه لايجاد هويه واحده لهذا
السودان باءت بالفشل الجنوب انفصل لان
المواطنون الجنوبيون كانوا يشعرون بانهم
مواطنون من الدرجه الثانيه ذلك ان هنالك
حكومه كانت تعتقد ان هنالك هويه واحده
لهذه البلاد يجب علينا في هذه البلاد ان
نعترف شكرا جزيلا ان نعترف اننا مختلفون
وانه لا يمكن لهويه واحده ان تسع هذا
القالب الضخم من الهويات والعادات
والتقاليد
والثقافات قالت انني عندما قلت اننا
متنوعون واننا مختلفون وان حدوث العنصريه
في مثل هذه الاجواء شيء طبيعي فانني اعطي
العنصريه تطبيعا او اعطيها صفه شرعيه ولكن
هذا هو الواقع الذي يجب ان نواجهه والذي
اسعى انا الى مواجهته الان بينما انت
تهربين منهان تتحدثين المجتمع غير قادر
الان المجتمع لديه حساسيات قديمه انا اود
تدمير هذه الحساسيات واود تدمير كل هذه
العقد عن طريق شرعنه هذا القرار السؤال عن
القبيله في الاوراق الثبوتيه هذا كان
تفنيدا لما تحدثت به الزميله في فريق
الموه العود الان الى طرح حجه الثانيه
والتي اعتقد انها سبب كافي جدا لكي يطرح
هذا السؤال في الاوراق في الاوراق
الثبوتيه اولا عنوان الحجه ان احصاء
القبائل وافرادها يسهل عمليه التنميه
النوعيه اولا يجب علينا ان نعلم ان هنالك
في علم الاحصاء الذي يستخدم في السياسه
يتم تقسيم السكان الى مجموعات ومن خلال
هذا التقسيم استطيع ان اقدم خدمه نوعيه
لهم كلنا نعلم ان هنالك فرق بين الذكر
والانثى ان هنالك فرق بين محدوديه الدخل
وعيه الدخل ان هنالك فرق بين كبار السن
وصغار السن هذه القبائل لازالت موجوده في
السودان في الارياف وفي الاقاليم لازالت
تحافظ على سلطتها وقوتها لذلك انني قد
احتاج في يوم من الايام الى التعامل مع
هذه القبائل فلا بد ان يكون لدي معلومات
كافيه عن تعداد هذه القبائل وافرادها
واستطيع الاستفاده من هذه من هذه
التعدادات في دراسه التهميش وتوزيع
التنميه واستطيع ايضا الاستفاده منه في
توفير معلومات كافيه للبحث العلمي
والدراسات واستطيع ايضا في المجال
الطبي في استطيع ايضا في المجال الطبي ان
اعطي خدمه افضل بامكاني مثلا الدراسه عن
الطلاب الجامعيين ومعرفه عدد القبائل عدد
عدد القبائل المهمشه في التعليم الجامعي
هل كل القبائل تاخذ حقها ام ان هناك قبيله
مهمشه وان اعود للاسباب وحاول معرفه هذه
الاسباب في القطاع الصحي ايضا استطيع ان
اعرف هل هناك قبيله مهمشه ام لا خصوصا
اننا في هذا الوطن مع هذا التنوع قد تحدث
دعوات كثيره جدا للانفصال وتحدث دعوات
كثيره جدا لتوحيد لايجاد هويه مت شركه
لهذه البلاد فعن طريق احصاء هذه القبائل
استطيع ايضا الاستفاده من هذا الاحصاء
مستقبلا وللاجيال القادمه ان يكون هنالك
احصاء بمجموع القبائل واعدادها وافرادها
في
هذهه البلاد ايضا نتحدث ان هنالك عنصريه
تمت عنصريه تم ممارستها من قبل الدوله ادت
الى فتق النسيج الاجتماعي لهذه البلاد
واستحواذ قبائل على وظائف وتهميش قبائل
اخرى بهذا التعداد وبهذا الاحصاء استطيع
وضع تمييز ايجابي مستقبلا استفيد منه
وشكرا
جزيلا نشكر الاستاذ احمد حياتي على خطابه
الثاني والذي استمر خمس دقائق ننتقل الان
الى المرحله الاخيره من المناظره والتي
تعنى بخطابات التفنيد فتتقدم الدكتوره
نجاه كيما تقدم خطاب
تفنيدها
اتيتكم مره اخرى في خطاب تلخيصي لما جرى
في المناظره ولكن قبل ان ابدا بتلخيص ما
جئت به من حجج ساعيد بناء المواقف التي
حاول فريق المعارضه عاجز هدمها وايضا هدم
النقاط الاخيره التي تحدث
فيها مارس لعبه قذره جدا في المناظرات
تسمى لعبه رجل القش و تحدث عن مفهوم
المواطنه وعن انني عندما تحدثت عن الفرق
ما بين القبيله والوطن تحدثت عن المواطنه
وبدا بالقاء درس في المواطنه عندما قارنت
ما بين القبيله وما بين الوطن تحدثت عن
فكره الانتماء ليس
الا قال بان
السؤال عن القبيله هو جزء من اسئله كثيره
تطرح في المجتمع او عند استخراج الوثائق
كتاريخ الميلاد والاسم واخبرته مرارا
وتكرارا باننا لا نتحسس ابدا من اعلان
تاريخ الميلاد كفتيات نفعل ذلك ولكن بعد
24 عاما الاسم ايضا بالنسبه لنا وكمجتمع
ليس شيئا ذو حساسيه ولكن سؤال القبيله
تحديدا في المجتمع السوداني لا يمكن
معاملته كسؤال طبيعي كسؤال عن الاسم تحدث
عندما قلت له باننا ندعو الى دوله قوميه
تعلو فيها المواطنه فوق كل شيء قال لي بان
هنالك محاولات جم
قد تمت حاول فيها ولكنها باءت بالفشل وضرب
مثالا بانفصال
الجنوب اذا فشلت المحاولات الفائته هل هذا
دافع لكي نتوقف عن المحاوله وهل عندما
انفصل الجنوب نقول بان انفصال الجنوب هو
نتيجه لفشل ونحن الان ايضا فاشلون فمرحبا
بانفصال الغ الغربي وجنوب كردفان وجنوب
النيل الازرق ونواصل في هذه المتواليه ام
ماذا اما في حجته المستقله
فقال بان هذه البيانات تستخدم في الاحصاء
فقط وفي التنميه
فقط سنحسن النيه وسنقول بان هذه
الاحصائيات ستستخدم في هذا المجال منذ
العام 2005 ماذا حدث وما نوع هذه الخدمات
التي ستقدمها بناء على القبيله مثلا يعني
هل هنالك احتياجات مختلفه للقبائل ام انت
تحتاج الى اسئله اخرى لتحدد مدى الحوجه ك
الدرجه التعليميه التي وصل اليها مستوى
دخل الفرد نوعه المنطقه الجغرافيه ما دخل
السؤال عن القبيله في تقديم الخدمات
النوعيه فعلا هذا ما يحدث تحديدا ما يحدث
تحديدا انه حينما ندلي باسم القبيله تتقدم
خدمات نوعيه لقبائل
معينه اما تلخيصا لما جئت به من محاور فان
النقطه الاولى تحدثت فيها لماذا ندعم
الغاء هذا السؤال ن دعم الغاء هذا السؤال
للحساسيه التي يتمتع بها وللمجتمع
السوداني الذي قد عان الكثير من العنصريه
يمارسها بطريقه يوميه في حياته اليوميه في
الاسواق في الظفر بالوظائف في تمثيل
الدوله داخليا وخارجيا نحن نتعايش بعنصريه
حتى وان انكرنا ذلك في مجتمع كهذا للسؤال
حساسيه مفرته لا يمكننا ان نتعامل معه
ببساطه ولان هنالك متضررون منه وجب على
الدوله التزاما اخلاقيا ان تقوم بسن
تشريعات تحمي المواطنه المتساويه وتحمي
هؤلاء المتضررين اما في نقطتي الثانيه
لماذا حددت الاوراق الثبوتيه تحديدا ذلك
لان موطن استخراج الاوراق الثبوتيه يفترض
ان يكون مكانا للمواطنه لجميع المواطنين
ليس الا وطرح السؤال في هذا المكان بالذات
انما يشكل خطرا كبيرا على الفكره القوميه
ومشروع الدوله القومي
والوطني تقول لي اخر الاوراق في صحفي ما
بين ضوئين تحلو عتمه النفق شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
نشكر الدكتوره نجاه احمد سليمان على
خطابها الرائع والذي استمر اربع دقائق
الان نكون قد وصلنا الى الخطاب الختامي في
هذه المناظره والذي سيقدمه الاستاذ احمد
حياتي فليتفضل
ذلك سر الكون ان تبصر ان تبصر في كل حسن
ايه لله والسحر الالهي المهيب ذلك سر
العدل ان تتفجر الاشياء تفصح عن قداستها
الجمهور الكريم في اخر الخطابات اعود
اليكم لاسر لكم ما جرى في هذه المناظره
بصوره بسيطه حتى اوريكم من كان احق بتوصيل
فكرته بصوره متميزه وواضحه ومن كان يلعب
على المنطق
والحجه
في اخر ما تحدثت عنه المتحدثه الزميله
وكان هو مفهوم الدوله القوميه هو ان نكون
دوله واحده يجب علينا ان نذكر ان من اهم
الحركات الوطنيه في السودان في الاستقلال
كانت جمعيه اللواء الابيض التي قامت في
العام
1919 اهم هذه الاسباب انه كان علي عبد
اللطيف وعبيد حاجه الامين يكتبون بيانا
للتهنئه بعيد الفطر مع مجموعه من من
الناشطين الاخرين وفي ديباجه البيان كتب
فيها يا ايها الشعب العربي الحر فثار علي
عبد اللطيف وثار عبيد حاجه الامين ان هذا
التعبير لا يعبر عن السودان تماما السودان
دوله بها ثقافات كثيره بها 520 قبيله بها
ما يقارب ال 300 لغه محليه كيف يكون لها
هويه واحده كيف يكون لها قوميه
واحده ان هذه هي المشكله التي واجهت
الدوله السودانيه منذ استقلالها اننا دوما
نحاول وضع هويه واحده وهذا ما لا يرضي
جميع اطراف هذا الشعب المختلف
الاطراف قالت ان انفصال الجنوب حدث ولكن
لم لم استطيع ان افهم ما علاقه انفصال
كردفان وانفصال دارفور السبب الاساسي
لانفصال الجنوب هو ان مواطني الجنوب كانوا
يحسون انهم مواطنون من الدرجه الثانيه هذا
التمييز نود القضاء عليه عن طري عن طريق
وضع اسم القبيله وهذا الشيء يساهم مستقبلا
وضع اسم القبيله في الاحصاءات التي تفيد
من تقديم تنميه نوعيه مستقبلا
قالت انها تعارض وضع السؤال لحساسيه
السؤال دعونا اولا نتفق ان سؤال القبيله
ليس عيبا او عارا وهي ايضا قالت كذلك ولكن
سؤال القبيله لديه حساسيه اذا ما الحل ان
نخفي السؤال ونحافظ على حساسيته ام ان
نواجهه وان نطرحه في الاوراق الثبوتيه وفي
المؤسسات الحكوميه مداخله شكرا جزيلا
ا قالت ايضا انني لعبت على حديثها وان
لعبت على مفهوم المواطنه ومفهوم القبيله
وان هذه الاماكن هي اماكن للمواطنه
الاماكن التي تستخرج منها الاوراق
الثبوتيه قلت لها ان مفهوم المواطنه هو
حقوق وواجبات وبناء على المعلومات التي
تقدمينها في الاوراق الثبوتيه يتم
الاعتراف بك كمواطنه احيانا توجد قبائل
لها دساتيرها الخاصه ولها شيوخها واعيان
وفي حال تجاوزت هذه الدساتير دستور
المواطنه في الحقوق والواجبات في هذه
اللحظه يجب فعليا ان يكون الوطن اعلى من
القبيله اما ف بقيه الحالات مثل الثقافات
والعادات والتقاليد فلا يوجد اي الغاء ولا
يوجد اي تضارب كون القبيله هي المؤسسه
الاساسي للوطن اعود الان الى موقفي وارى
انني كنت واضحا انني اعترف تماما بهذا
الاختلاف وبهذا التنوع واسعى لان نعترف
كلنا بهذا الاختلاف وان نتقبل كلنا بعضنا
الاخر وهذا لا يتم اذا كان هذا السؤال
عيبا وعارا يجب علينا ان نعترف بقبائل
وبثقافة
واحده على بقيه الهويات فان ذلك يؤدي
بالضروره الى حدوث مشاكل في هذه البلاد
وسردت حجتين الحجه الاولى اعترفت فيها
بالتنوع واعترفت انني اود مواجهه حساسيه
هذا السؤال وتجريده من حساسيته شكرا جزيلا
و في الحجه الثانيه تحدثت ان هذا الاحصاء
يقدم تنميه نوعيه وقد سالتني في اخر
حديثها عن اي تنميه نوعيه اتحدث تحدثت لك
عن مفهوم التهميش ان هنالك جهات مع او
قبائل معينه بصوره غير واضحه بصوره غير
مقصوده عن طريق معلومات داخل هذه القبيله
او ثقافات قد لا تذهب الى سلك التعليم عن
طريق هذه الاوراق الثبوتيه استطيع ان اعرف
عدد المنتمين للقبائل المعينه في التعليم
المعين وارى اذا كانت هنالك قبيله مهمشه
نظرا لثقافات او عادات داخل هذه القبيله
وان اقوم بمحاربه هذه العادات وهذه
التقاليد تحدثت لك ايضا اننا في حقل الب
البحث العلمي نحتاج الى تعداد ونحتاج الى
الارقام حتى نقدم اوراقا علميه قويه بوجود
هذا التعداد انا استفيد منها تحدثت لك
ايضا ان في مجال الطب ان هنالك اوبئه او
هنالك فيروسات تتفاعل مع جينات معينه فاذا
كان لدي تعداد معين استطيع ان اقدم خدمه
معينه وان استطيع ان اقدم تطعيم معين لهذه
الاجيال هذا ما كان في سؤالك لي عن ماهيه
التنميه النوعيه لهذه القبائل وانا لا
اقصد العنصريه با ب شكل من الاشكال في اخر
الكلام اقول علينا انه يجب علينا ان نواجه
هذه العنصريه ويجب علينا ان نضع هذا
السؤال حاجزا بيننا وان نعترف بوجود جميع
القبائل وذلك لا يتاتى الا عندما نجرد هذا
السؤال من حساسيته ومن قوته المفرطه وشكرا
جزيلا
[تصفيق]
لكم صفقه لل
المتناظرين
طيب ده نموذج يعني للنقاش المتحضر من
خلاله بيكون المجتمع قادر يصل لمرحله من
التفاهم واداره التنوع والاختلاف نقاش
زيده اذا كان بيحصل على مستوى يعني
المجموعات الشبابيه على مستوى المجموعات
السياسيه في البلد بل حتى على مستوى
الاسره انا استطيع يعني ان اؤكد لكم انه
البلد دي حتمشي بخطوات متسارعه نحو التقدم
والتطور طيب طبعا احنا دائما بنقول انه
يعني كل المتناظرين فائزين لكن لابد يكون
في فائز وخاسر فالفائز والخاسر هنا ما
بيحددوا حكم انما بتحددوها انتم فانا عايز
الناس تكون صادقه يا جماعه انا عارف اي
زول عنده وجهه نظر تجاه القضيه دي لكن
يعني اجتهدوا معي ويكونوا
صادقين من
المناظره اللي تمت الان امامكم وال بتتحدث
عن وجوب الغاء سؤال القبيله من الاوراق
الثبوتيه شايفين انه متحدثه الموالاه
والتي تدعم الغاء سؤال القبيله من الاوراق
الثبوتيه كانت مقنعه ارفعوا يدهم يا جماعه
بكل صدق
يعني طيب طيب انتم يعني شايفين الحكايه دي
هسي ده ما رايكم الشخصي يعني طيب طيب
الراي الشخصي في الموضوع ده انه يجب الغاء
القبيله يرفع يده الراي
الشخصي طيب ما يا جماعه ما انتوا نفسكم
يعني
يعني ما تمها واضحه يعني طيب شاايف انه
يعني متحدث المعارضه كان مقنع وكان يعني
واضح تماما يرفع
يده طيب طيب برضو حقوم اسالكم نفس السؤال
الاصلا فعليا يعني شايف انه يعني متبني
الراي بتاع المعارضه يرفع يده يعني من
بدري واضح انه هنا في ناس غيرت رايه
فعليا واضح انه في يعني اكويليبريوم حاصل
او توازن وده ان كان في سبب له انما هو
جوده المناظره يعني واتقانه فصفق ثاني لل
المتناظرين وفي الختام نشكركم على حسن
اسباع مركز السودان للمناظرات كان هو
المقدم لهذه المناظره بالتعاون مع منظمي
فعاليه تدكس على راسم الشكر الجزيل
للاستاذ والدكتور انور ادفع
الله اتمنى نكون قدمنا فقره نوعيه يعني
للفعاليه
دي شكرا
[موسيقى]
ك